هنا جرت احدى اهم معارك الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
في المكان ذاته روسيا تحتفل بذكرى هزيمه
الالمان وتستعرض قوتها العسكريه
العرض العسكري يوازيه حشد روسي شرقي
اوكرانيا تاهبا لشن اكبر هجوم منذ بدء
الحرب حيث تم حشد نحو 500 الف جندي لتنفيذ
هذا الهجوم او وفق وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
الذي توقع ان يبدا الهجوم تزامنا مع
الذكرى الاولى للحرب المخاوف الاوكرانيه
من حمله جديده
رافقها
بضغط روسي يستهدف الشرق في ليمان وبخمود
بخموت المحاصره بشرق اوكرانيا يتركز
القتال حولها بعد اكثر من عشره شهور من
المعارك الداميه التي استنزفت الطرفين اما
في منطقه دومباس فتكثف روسيا حجم قواتها
بشكل كبير سعيا للسيطره عليها وتستعد
موسكو لفتح جبهه جديده حيث تسعى الى ان
تتقدم قواتها عبر الحدود الروسيه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي فلتت من قبضتها في سوم اوخر
كيف
مئات الالاف من القوات واستهداف عشرات
الاماكن يوميا استراتيجيه القوات الروسيه
بينما تقديرات المخابرات الاوكرانيه تشير
الى ان روسيا نشرت ما يقرب من 300 وعشرين
الف جندي مؤخرا اوكرانيا التي تنتظر
الدبابات والعربات المدرعه وانظمه الاسلحه
الاخرى من الغرب تكافح للاحتفاظ بارضها
على امتداد
2025 كيلومترا في الشرق
عصام عبد السلام العربيه